hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for anime outpour and today i will
be diving into one of the biggest and
most intriguing mysteries in the world
of one piece who is the enigmatic joyboy
and have we already met him in the story
without even realizing it strap
yourselves in for the voyage as we break
down all the best theories on joyboy's
true identity and his or her true
intentions there are so many compelling
theories out there and i'm even getting
my boy teching 101 to help me out on
this one so let's get into it if you
guys enjoy the one piece content on this
channel and you want to see more just
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps with
the youtube algorithm and if you're new
to the channel or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications finally
this video will of course contain one
piece manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned okay
so here's what we know about joy boys so
far even though it might seem like the
mystery of joyboy has been looming over
us forever the first time he was
mentioned was actually in chapter 628
when robin reads the ryugyu ponoglyph
inside the sea forest this means that
joyboy was first mentioned like 14 years
after the manga started its publication
which is just insane when you think
about it on the ryugyu ponoglyph a man
from the surface known as joyboy is
apologizing to the people of fishman
island for breaking his part of an
ancient promise a promise related to the
true purpose of the giant ark known as
noah this apology was written during the
void century meaning that joy boy is an
important historical figure from the
void century and the nature of this
letter shows that this joy boy had a
strong and very personal connection to
the people of fishman island despite the
fact that he himself was from the
surface joyboy is believed to have lived
some 900 years ago so at the beginning
of the void century but since the
poneglyphs are believed to have been
invented by the kosuki clan some 800
years ago the ryugyupanoglyph must have
been created around the end of the void
century so there seems to be a gap of
about 100 years between the time that
joy boy is believed to have made a
promise to the people of fishman island
and the time that the ryukyuponoglyph
was actually created in terms of the
promise itself it seems that the people
of fishman island promised to keep noah
safe until a certain day arrived keeping
noah safe was there part of the promise
joy boy's part of the promise was most
likely that he would use the power of
poseidon to bring noah up to the surface
it is also likely that noah's true
purpose was to serve as an ark that
would relocate all the people of fishman
island up to the surface something that
many fishermen have dreamed of for
centuries but were never able to achieve
due to the rampant discrimination that
they faced on the surface joy boy is
also the man who left a priceless
treasure known as the one piece on a
mysterious island at the end of the new
world this island was discovered by
goldie roger and his crew 25 years ago
and roger named the island laugh tale
because he thought that the truth about
the world that was revealed to him on
that island was a funny story roger's
crew is believed to be the first to step
foot on this secret island since the
void century since the people of fishman
island continue to faithfully watch over
noah in order to keep their end of the
promise to joyboy it is implied that
this joyboy will one day return to
fulfill his part of the promise to the
people of fishman island but how could
this man known as joyboy possibly return
to keep his promise when he lived like
900 years ago he must have died many
many centuries ago right something
doesn't really add up here and this is
only the beginning of the mystery so
let's jump straight into the joy boy
rabbit hole there are several possible
scenarios for how joy boy could be an
important historical figure who lived
900 years ago and someone who is
expected to one day return in order to
fulfill an important role in the current
timeline of the story the first scenario
is that joy boy really is one single
individual but he is someone who is
either a immortal b a time traveler or c
a drastically different type of life
form from what we're used to seeing in
one piece now these options might sound
crazy but within the world of one piece
we already have the concept of
immortality the concept of time travel
and life forms that live a very very
long time a number of devil fruits have
already been shown to be able to slow or
even halt the aging process including
laws of pop fruit or the opeopenomi and
sugar's hobi hominomi the hobie hobi
nomi seems to grant eternal youth to its
user and it also halts the aging process
in those who were transformed into toys
but the op-op fruit which is also
rightly referred to as the opop fruit is
even more interesting its greatest power
known as the perennial youth operation
or the immortality operation allows its
user to grant immortality to another
person the current devil fruit user has
to forfeit their own life in the process
but in return the person on whom this
operation is performed becomes immortal
doflamingo reveals that the world nobles
possess a quote-unquote national
treasure that could be used in
combination with the op-up fruit in
order to conquer the entire world since
we know that a devil fruit will
reincarnate once its user dies it is
possible that previous users of the
op-op fruit used the immortality
operation to make someone else immortal
many people believe that imusama could
be an immortal being that may have been
made immortal through this procedure and
so perhaps joy boy was also made
immortal using the op-op fruit at some
point during the void century the other
possibility is that the original joy boy
could have been kept alive using some
sort of technological procedure such as
cryonics cloning or being turned into a
cyborg of some kind again this type of
technology has been heavily foreshadowed
in one piece especially through the work
of dr vegapunk vegapunk himself is
another huge mystery and he has never
been properly introduced into the story
although his inventions have played an
important role for hundreds and hundreds
of chapters we know that he has studied
devil fruits including the creation of
artificial devil fruits he has studied
cloning and he has researched the
lineage factor the blueprint of all life
if anyone could figure out a way to make
joyboy or someone else live longer or
perhaps even forever it would be
vegapunk and since vegapunk's age is
unknown he himself could be hundreds of
years old assuming that he might have
figured out a way to make himself live
for centuries vegapunk could even be
joyboy in the flesh a genius inventor
driven to become immortal in order to
finally keep his promise to fishman
island that said though vegapunk could
also just be a normal human with a
normal human lifespan and the same might
be true of joyboy and yet if he could
say travel forward in time joyboy would
be able to live during the void century
and during the modern era without
needing to become immortal and just as
with immortality the power of time
travel already exists in one piece
odin's wife toki has the tokitoki no me
a devil fruit that enables her to send
herself and others forward in time toki
herself was apparently born some 830
years ago so during the void century and
she traveled all the way up to the
modern era which is where she first met
odin some 30 years ago and became his
wife she was last seen 20 years ago when
she used her devil fruit to send momo
and several of the scabbards 20 years
forward in time before seemingly being
killed i say seemingly because i have a
hunch that toki is not dead yet toki was
born during the void century and outside
of wano so she probably possesses
incredibly important information about
the lost history of the one piece world
the fact that she never got a chance to
reveal much of it just seems odd to me
and i could totally see her appearing at
some point in the future i mean she may
still be dying from the injuries she
sustained 20 years ago but she may have
launched herself forward in time just
before her death in order to reveal some
important intel about the void century
and joy boy just before passing away
because she is from the void century it
is possible that toki herself could be
leading a double life as the infamous
joy boy in that case the real reason why
she was traveling forward in time was to
fulfill joy boy's promise when the time
was right and so joy boy was actually
not a boy at all joy boy was tolkie all
along a twist so crazy that it made
roger laugh out loud i'm not saying that
this is likely but it would be pretty
funny since odin's wife is not exactly
the first person you might suspect of
being the legendary joy boy that said
though even if toki isn't joy boy she
may have known him during the void
century and she may have sent him
forward in time to the modern era which
is why he could still be alive today
finally joy boy could just be a creature
with a massive lifespan that allows him
to remain among the living from the void
century up to the present moment we know
that giants in one piece can live as
long as 350 years and after the reveal
of that massive frozen straw hat in mary
joaz many have speculated that joy boy
may have been a giant now of course a
350-year lifespan may be long but it's
not long enough to take us from the void
century up to the present that said the
world of one piece could be home to
other creatures with even longer
lifespans and joyboy may be one of them
for example we know that the ancient
giants exist and that they differ from
regular giants in that they can grow up
to three times as large as a regular
giant there are only two known members
of this group in the story oars and
little oars junior so we don't have
enough information to determine what
kind of lifespan the ancient giants
possessed but if they could live three
times as long as regular giants just as
they can grow three times as tall as
regular giants then an ancient giant
could easily live from the time of the
void century all the way up to the
present time and if joy boy really was
this massive ancient giant who is still
alive today it would make for one of the
craziest character introductions in the
history of manga that said we also have
a second scenario a scenario that
stipulates that the original joy boy
from the void century is long dead but
he has been reincarnated into the modern
world again reincarnation does kind of
have a precedent in one piece through
the devil fruits which are somehow
reincarnated every time their user dies
but that is clearly different from human
reincarnation and yet there are a few
sections of the story that seem to hint
at the possibility that someone alive
today could be a reincarnation of joy
boy and of course the idea that luffy
might be joy boy's reincarnation is a
very popular one among fans
reincarnation is not a very well
established concept in western culture
and western religions but it is actually
widely accepted and even taken for
granted in many eastern cultures and
religions hinduism and buddhism both
accept reincarnation as a given and
buddhism in particular has been highly
influential in japanese culture and
society for many centuries since one
piece is absolutely full of direct
references to buddhism and buddhist
symbolism we shouldn't be surprised if
one day human reincarnation is
introduced into the story maybe in the
form of joy boy during the odin
flashback roger and odin hear two
seekings talking about what sounds like
an extremely important prophecy the
seekings say the birthing is at hand our
sovereign shall soon be born and another
in a distant sea the whales are
delighted in anticipation of the day the
two sovereigns shall meet again we have
been waiting for so long and it's almost
here and surely all will go well this
time just 10 until the birth and another
15 to grow one of the sovereigns has to
be shirakoshi who was born 10 years
later and who is the current incarnation
of the ancient weapon poseidon but who
is the other sovereign and what do the
sea kings mean when they say that the
two sovereigns will meet again how can a
sovereign who won't even be born for
another 10 years meet with someone again
this conversation between the two
seekings heavily implies that some sort
of reincarnation may be at play here if
we accept that one of the sovereigns is
the modern incarnation or reincarnation
of poseidon then who is the other
sovereign and who are they the
reincarnation of it's safe to assume
that the other sovereign is likely joy
boy himself since we know he had a
connection to poseidon and fishman
island during the void century and since
he made a promise to them that he still
needs to keep presumably something
happened during the void century that
prevented the promise from being kept
but the sea kings believed that
everything will go well this time around
we also know that wano was closed off
from the rest of the world for a reason
that was connected to joy
and odin was convinced that joyboy would
return some 20 years after his own
execution that time has now arrived and
who is the person that has already made
a massive impact on fishman island and
formed a friendship with poseidon straw
hat luffy of course
and there are a lot of things pointing
to the fact that luffy could be some
sort of reincarnation of joy boy and i
don't just mean the fact that he's the
main character although in shonen that
definitely doesn't hurt there are
multiple things that make luffy unique
and that make us think that he might be
the quote unquote chosen one the
reincarnation of joy boy who is destined
to finally complete joy boy's ultimate
mission luffy is one of the very few
people who can hear the voice of all
things he has the uncanny ability to
draw people to him and rally them to his
cause and he has the kind of limitless
resolve and determination that allows
him to overcome every single obstacle
that is placed in his way and then
there's shirley's prophecy that a man
wearing a straw hat will destroy fishman
island this man with a straw hat is
widely believed to be luffy himself but
why would luffy ever want to destroy
fishman island a place he fought to
protect and a place where he made some
great friends assuming that this
prophecy is true it might not be what it
seems luffy may destroy fishman island
as we know it not by actually
annihilating it but by finally
fulfilling joyboy's promise if luffy is
the reincarnation of joyboy and if he
uses the noah to transport the
inhabitants of fishman island up to the
surface then yeah fishman island as we
know it would be no more but the people
of fishman island would actually be
better off there's also the relatively
recently introduced sun god nika a
legendary warrior who was worshipped as
the sun god by slaves in ancient times
the legend of nika says that he would
one day come to liberate all the slaves
and bring smiles to their faces and this
immediately makes us think that the
legend of nikka and the legend of joy
boy could be one in the same not only
that but the silhouette that we see of
nica looks a lot like the silhouette of
luffy while he was dancing back in
skypia so the implication here is clear
nika and joyboy could be the same person
an ancient warrior who wanted to
liberate those who were enslaved and
oppressed such as the fishman and luffy
could be the reincarnation of this
ancient warrior and so he may be
destined to succeed where the original
joyboy failed i watched several videos
that have some really great theories
about who the original joy boy was in
terms of his role in the void century
including videos by o'hara and our tour
library of ohara which i will link down
in the description below my personal
favorite theory is that joyboy was the
leader or one of the leaders of the
ancient kingdom that fought against the
alliance of 20 kingdoms which eventually
formed the world government during the
void century joyboy's ancient kingdom
sought to unite all the different races
and to end elitist hierarchical rule and
inequality this is why he promised to
help the fishman they were one of the
oppressed and disenfranchised groups
that he was trying to liberate joyboy's
ancient kingdom may have been based on
the so-called pirate kingdoms which
appeared during the golden age of piracy
in our own world these were basically
small regions that were completely
controlled by pirates and privateers and
independent from the authority of any
other government the most prominent
example of this was probably the
so-called republic of pirates which
controlled parts of the bahamas between
1706 and 1718. knowing what we know
about joyboy and pirates in general in
the context of the one-piece world it is
possible that the ancient kingdom
embraced the ideals of freedom and
equality in a way that directly
threatened the position of the other
established kingdoms of the world after
all if these other kingdoms were based
on strict hierarchical rule slavery and
discrimination a rival kingdom that
promised to free all the slaves and
discrimination and promote freedom and
equality to all would be a massive
threat to their very existence no wonder
that as many as 20 kingdoms united in an
alliance to destroy the ancient kingdom
if they hadn't we likely would have seen
something similar to what happened in
our own world the spread of ideals such
as freedom equality and democracy
eventually led to the destruction of
absolutist monarchical rule and although
some monarchies did survive in our own
modern world they are completely
different from what they used to be and
the actual power that royal families
have in those countries is only symbolic
not real power however in the world of
one piece joy boy and the ancient
kingdom were defeated by the alliance of
20 kingdoms which may have been led by
imusama him or herself depending on
whether or not imusama is an immortal
being once the 20 kingdoms won the war
they decided to form the world
government and completely erase the
ancient kingdom and everything related
to it from history as clover from the
library of o'hara implied the world
government didn't try so hard to erase
the ancient kingdom from history because
it feared its warriors or its weapons
the world government feared the ancient
kingdom's ideals and if those ideals
were freedom and equality then it all
makes sense using our own world as an
example we know that these ideas are
extremely powerful and that they changed
the world as we know it the old system
of monarchical rule slavery
discrimination and so on was completely
turned upside down through a series of
wars and revolutions that eventually led
to the world we have today the world
government wanted to avoid the fate of
absolutist monarchies in our own world
so they attempted to erase all traces of
joyboy and the ancient kingdom and
everything they represented from history
after all if the people of the modern
world are never exposed to such ideas
they will never get a chance to fight
for them and the status quo will be
maintained it's possible that wanna was
part of joyboy's kingdom and so the
kozuki sealed themselves off from the
outside world and created the ponoglyphs
in order to ensure that history wouldn't
be completely forgotten and that the
legacy of joy boy in the ancient kingdom
would live on this is the truth that
odin might have discovered on laugh tale
along with the fact that the
reincarnated joy boy would soon return
to ano and so it had to be opened up yet
again and while most advocates of the
reincarnation theory believe that the
top candidate for the new joy boy is
luffy there are other potential
candidates as well including momonosuke
vivi and so on but what if this isn't
about reincarnation at all scenario 3
suggests that joyboy was not directly
reincarnated into this world but that
his will has somehow continued to live
in others and specifically the members
of the infamous d clan the idea is that
all members of the d-clan could be
direct descendants of joy boy or joy boy
and his crew and so they are all
potential candidates for becoming the
new joy boy the will of d or the will of
joy boy might be some sort of
supernatural force that connects all
living beings and can be used to guide
the course of history something like the
force in star wars or maybe the ancient
mysterious weapon uranus is actually the
will of d or rather maybe uranus was
used to somehow project joyboy's will
into the modern world through the d clan
there are many theories and many of them
are very interesting but personally i
think it would be cool if every member
of the d-clan had the potential to
harness this supernatural force known as
the will of d if the right circumstances
are met so yeah luffy might have been
chosen by fate to become a great man
which makes him a chosen one but because
there are others with the same potential
to harness the will of thee such as for
example blackbeard there is no guarantee
that luffy will be the one to come out
on top in the end this would make the
ending of one piece much more exciting
because it won't just be a continuous
progression to luffy's inevitable and
destined success the climax would be a
lot more uncertain because of wild cards
like blackbeard finally there is a
scenario in which joyboy is just a title
a symbol or an idea the term joyboy
simply represents the ideals of freedom
and equality and there is no
supernatural element to it at all the
modern successor of joyboy will just be
someone who embodies his ideals someone
like luffy but there is no direct
connection between luffy and the
original joyboy this is also possible
but i don't think that's the most likely
scenario because it wouldn't necessarily
explain a whole bunch of things
including the idea of the d clan the
shirely prophecy the words of the sea
kings about the two specific sovereigns
from the past who are somehow going to
meet again and so on personally i really
like the idea of joy boy being one of
the leaders of the ancient kingdom which
tried to establish a political system
based on the ideas of freedom and
equality for everyone including humans
fishmen giants minks tontaras lunarians
and so on this idea of freedom and
equality probably gained traction very
quickly since there are many oppressed
people in the world of one piece and so
the rulers of the 20 kingdoms who wanted
to preserve the status quo formed an
alliance defeated the ancient kingdom
and then tried to erase it from history
thus creating the void century luffy is
either the reincarnation of joy boy or
one of the inheritors of joy boy's will
through his membership in the d clan but
luffy's ultimate victory is not assured
because there are other candidates for
harnessing the will of joy boy for their
own ends including blackbeard i believe
that a void sentry flashback arc and a
new massive war arc will happen before
the series finally ends and i can't wait
to see what happens next let me know
which theory about joyboy's identity is
your favorite down in the comments below
and don't forget to like and subscribe
if you want to see more content like
this we've covered a lot of ground in
this video so far so now i'm going to
bring in teching 101 to bring the entire
discussion home and joining me today the
one man who knows more about one piece
world history and geography than the
average person knows about the real
world history and geography the one the
only teching 101
hi everybody that was a great
introduction thank you for that oh
absolutely bro it is my pleasure to have
you on because i have so much respect
for your one piece knowledge and we've
talked many times on the one piece
virgin podcast and on many other
podcasts ranked cafe
about one piece and i as you know i got
caught up fairly recently in the grand
scheme of things so it's been quite a
journey and it's a pleasure to have you
here to talk about joy boy perhaps the
most enigmatic figure in all of one
piece
absolutely and points for using
engematic i love that word yes enigmatic
it's uh it's a thing that i use in my
everyday life
i used it i said it to one of my friends
the other day and he's just like i don't
know what that means and i'm just like
yeah that's kind of the point of the
word it's a more mysterious way of
saying mysterious exactly i love it but
yeah joy boy man yeah that's one of the
final end goals and theories for the
entire story it's right up there with
will of d and one piece treasure i mean
like who's joy boy that's like that big
yeah and we know that joy boy actually
left this one piece treasure at least
that's the implication from what roger
says during the odin flashback joy boy
is the one who left the treasure so it's
like he started everything
yeah the impression i got from that
scene was literally like the one-piece
treasure part of it is some kind of
story that roger was like reading or
odin read to him and then he was
laughing at that story and he was like
oh joy boy you left such a funny story
for us you know yes same here yeah i
thought that too but then again oda has
apparently said that the one piece
treasure will be an actual treasure like
oh no no i didn't mean i didn't mean to
see i this happens all the time where
i'll say like i think part of the
one-piece treasure is literally just a
pile of gold and people will be like
what do you mean it's just a pile of
gold i don't mean it's just that i mean
it's that plus a bunch of other stuff
like it's like a lot of stuff yeah so i
think i think part of it's going to be
maybe a mural or a story on a wall of
like what joy boy's tale is but also
it's like actual treasure along the way
is that as well yeah or something even
crazier than treasure like uranus or
uranus yes yeah yeah iran as sooranos
however you want to say ancient weapons
or or something that could destroy the
red line i mean the list goes on yeah uh
and before i get into any theories uh on
my end i want to see what your kind of
prevailing theory is at the moment and
you mentioned you actually had some new
thoughts recently so let's talk yeah
so um given what kaido said to luffy
when he knocked him off the side of
onigishima he was like oh it looks like
it wasn't you you know implying there
that joy boy was more of a title rather
than like just one person at one point
in time yeah um i get i you know i i
like the idea of reincarnation i mean
that's cool to an extent but i probably
prefer it more of like everybody that
has the will of d
is sort of a candidate to become the
next joy boy all right like joy boy was
maybe just one person way back during
the void century but then he died and he
passed his will on to everyone that
bears the will of d and whitebeard kind
of confirms this a little bit when he
fought blackbeard at marineford he's
like you know the one
roger's waiting for is not you teach
implying that like oh yeah everybody
that has the wheel of d could be the
next joy boy but whitebeard's like no
even if you have it blackbeard it's not
gonna be you it's gonna be somebody else
um so i would love the idea for luffy to
have it of course because he's the main
character and everything but then the
new idea i kind of arrived at just
recently was like why does it only have
to be one person that bears the title of
joy boy what if it's luffy and law that
both meet the criteria and they're both
considered joy boy
you know something like that or maybe
they have to actually work together in
order to accomplish the prophecy
exactly yeah i was looking i was uh
reviewing some uh joy boy related videos
in the preparation for this video and i
know o'hara had a interesting video
where his theory was that joy boy was
the leader of the ancient kingdom and
that he his the whole point was joy boy
went to war against what is today the
world government but lost
and that is why he failed the promise
to fishman island because uh ohara's
idea was that joy boy wanted to
eliminate uh racial divisions and things
like that and it helped fishman island
go up to the surface but
he failed to do that because they ended
up losing the war however once the
second war occurs the one that in the
odin flashback that is referred to as
this massive war that will make you know
the seas yeah yeah like it's been it's
been referenced before even doflamingo
kind of referenced it like the throne
wars or whatever you want to call it
yeah yeah the game of thrones
yeah perhaps then
joy boy's mission will be completed but
then again the question is then is it
just an idea so this leader of the
ancient kingdom is just an idea a cause
or
is it more of a reincarnation or is it
like an actual will so the will itself
being something more than just you know
the idea of being like
a force kind of like the force in star
wars i don't know it's hard to say but
we definitely do have things like devil
fruit which you know the d is common
there yeah
and they do they do reincarnate in a way
right they do absolutely that they they
literally do i i always feel like
because everyone's always like what's
the d stand for and i think like the d
will have like a meaning like a word
that it stands for and the meaning
itself might be very simple i've heard
devil i've heard dawn like the dawn of a
new era you know all these different d
words you can come up with um but i
think it's what's going to be more
relevant than just the actual name of
like whatever the d stands for is like
the spirit or the will behind it that's
why it's literally called the will of d
it's just like yeah it does stand for
this but what it stands for is more
important than that if that makes sense
yeah my only my only question would be
then would this be
a some sort of supernatural force or
would it be just the concept of you know
freedom or equality or whatever i think
to the point where we're at in one piece
right now like it could not be done
unless there was some kind of
supernatural force involved like the
force you said in star wars because it's
just like you know the idea is like they
are reincarnated sort of like at least
the name carries on and like there's
certain things like you look at luffy
and you look at roger and you look at
all these other pirates that have the
will of d and you look at joy boy we
don't know much about joy boy but we
have a general idea and it's like man a
lot of these people all seem to have the
exact same kind of
motivation and will and stuff you know
to be free like that's the ultimate kind
of overlying theme of one piece is to be
free yeah so it's just like well you
could say that like people like that
will pop up in every generation uh but
you could say also like they're linked
through the will of d you know
no yeah for sure and i mean um
there's a lot of interesting things at
play here
and i just wonder how it's all gonna
turn out because we had uh during again
the odin flashback
we had those sea kings the neptunians
uh mentioned something about the two
sovereigns are going to be born soon
they're going to be born
in 10 years they're gonna be born
shirakoshi and then in 15 years she's
going to grow up and then the two
summers are going to meet
so that's something that's something i
mentioned before i did a video i can't
remember how long ago it was but it was
the basic idea that like there's certain
criteria for this event to happen and it
falls in line with what roger said about
he was being too early and so i'm
thinking all right there has to be a
mermaid princess and also that has the
power of poseidon because not all
mermaid princesses have it but like they
have to be poseidon and a joy boy
reincarnate and they have to be there at
kind of the same time and sometimes
they're not so in the case with roger he
was maybe the title of joy boy but the
mermaid princess wasn't around yet so he
couldn't finish it yeah and the
interesting thing is
the neptunians are talking about these
sovereigns as
the same
sovereigns that lived before yeah
they're saying they're gonna meet again
and yet we know it's supposed to be in
the future and then they say something
wrong lines as um hopefully it will all
go well this time as if you know last
time the last great war it didn't go
well and joy boy couldn't complete his
promise so that's what
that type of stuff makes me think yeah
it's more than just the idea of freedom
and joy boy being like a freedom fighter
um against the world government or
whatever it seems to be more of like a
supernatural force that returns
what if the supernatural force in
question is literally just the devil
fruits because we don't know how long
they've existed and from what we found
out recently with the gum ogamunomi
apparently the government really wanted
that fruit like it was extremely
important yes it's not and it's not
ridiculously powerful i mean it's a
strong fruit but it's not like the
strongest fruit ever so that makes me
think what if it was literally joy boy's
fruit and so he had it and so luffy now
has it and it's like you know the
government doesn't want that fruit to be
in circulation it's the same reason why
eem keeps that giant straw hat in the
basement at marijuana it's just like
anything related to joy boy has to be
removed from society and from history
yeah yes exactly yeah and that is
interesting because we know how luffy
got the fruit shanks takes it he goes
through a lot of trouble to take it from
the world government and then some kid
just randomly like eats it at the bar
i mean you could say it's it's just a
huge uh coincidence or its fate or
was shanks maybe planning something was
that all according to his plan i don't
know it's interesting so i would go
along with the idea that shanks
specifically targeted that like maybe
shanks heard the legend from roger or he
heard it from somebody else and he found
out that hey the gamugamunomi is really
important to the government i'm going to
steal it so i believe that like shanks
planned that it wasn't just an accident
he ended up with
me but i do feel like it was just an
accident that luffy ate it i feel like
they just brought it into the bar to
have it with them at all times so they
wouldn't lose it but they're also really
big partiers shanks's crew are so they
just get drunk and then they just luffy
eats it it's like oh [ __ ] we messed up
so i think that would fit with oda's
humor a little bit you know it is kind
of like in terms of how significant it
is it almost seems like comical but i
mean oda does do that type of stuff and
i mean i guess shanks wasn't trying to
become joy boy if let's say he knew all
of this presumably he would have eaten
the fruit right away right so he either
didn't know the whole story
or he wasn't necessarily trying to
become joy boy himself
presumably i mean we don't know how long
he had the fruit before he ate it i mean
it might just be like hey we caught the
fruit let's uh let's party for a couple
of days and then i'll eat it or
something that might be the reason
shanks doesn't have one maybe he
literally was
waiting to eat the gamugamunomi because
yeah how do you feel about shanks having
the will of d because i feel like he has
it
yeah i mean he's such an important and
mysterious character himself so i and
the whole straw hat connection so i
think he must there must be something
about him but
we're gonna definitely find more about
him um in some kind of flashback that's
coming
and i do think that will of the
it would make sense for him to have it
like it just it's almost weird that he
doesn't when we know so many other
people who do including or he's he's
maybe smart enough to know like he told
roger what his name was and rogers like
yeah maybe don't tell everybody that
that's your name and so he that's why he
just goes by shanks
yes no yeah that makes sense that makes
sense i think the criteria for what joy
boy wanted is that you have to have joy
boy
uh mermaid princess with the power of
poseidon and they both have to be at the
same location probably laugh tale at the
same time for this to um happen whatever
it is i think it might be the
destruction of the red line like
marijuana falling to the ground and the
red line collapsing and the whole world
becoming unified i mean that was a
popular theory for a while yeah and i
mean that is
kind of something that would make for an
epic climactic war arc so i think that
is
very possible and i definitely think
that the neptunians are going to play a
major role in it because of the
connection with poseidon and the fact
that roger and luffy understand them all
of that is going to be
playing into it i think
yeah
the neptunians are like super ancient
too they could be like thousands and
thousands of years old so this might
have happened maybe multiple times from
their perspective yeah and they seem to
know what's happening they seem to know
what's going to happen again and i
wonder i wonder how oda is going to
explain the fact that history is
cyclical in such a way is it just gonna
be uh oh you know eventually when the
conditions are met this ends up
happening is it gonna be some sort of
like supernatural curse or something
that
kind of forces these people to reenact
this like it's
yeah i wonder how he's gonna explain it
because i'm sure it's gonna be very very
interesting um i know also the moon is
probably going to be involved nox has
had his big theories about the moon he
even had a theory that the d might
actually be like a uh
moon in like when you i i i mean
maybe moors that mentioned this but like
if you look at just the picture the
image of the straw hat like just look at
the one piece logo and the hat on top of
the skull and it's like it kind of looks
like the sun rising over the horizon
because you have like the half circle
then the red band kind of looks like the
light reflecting off the water so maybe
that's it and that kind of looks like a
d in its own right so yeah yeah like
there's a lot of ways i think oda could
spin this yeah and i think that you know
with the whole of sun god stuff
happening recently in wano
you know the sun god was very similar
looking to luffy so everything seems to
be pointing at luffy being joy boy but
like you said it might be more
complicated than that i feel like since
he's the main character if joy boy is a
title everybody's gonna be like yeah
luffy's gonna be troy boy like obviously
it's pointed to it and i'm like okay we
could still have that but let's have
like maybe law is also joy boy or
something like you could have that as
well yeah and i think law is so
interesting too because of his devil
fruit which can apparently make other
people
immortal and then we have
vegapunk and his stuff happening right
so i i
and then of course toki and her time
traveling fruit so it's like
yes joy boy might just be a sort of
inherited will
but
there's people who have could
potentially be immortal who live in the
world who actually lived through the
void century like we know toki did yeah
toki did um i'm actually under the
impression vegapunk is way old and he's
just like a cyborg or a robot that's
like same here he he might be like 500
years old for all we know you know yeah
same here i have that impression as well
and also
emu
definitely he might be we have no idea i
mean he could be a ghost he could be a
vampire for all we know like i'm not
being serious but he could be and he had
no idea what he is yeah yeah yeah so i
think definitely the you know the most
popular theory will be that luffy is joy
but and then the clues seem to point to
it but i think you have a good point
when you say that it could be more
complicated than that it might require
you know a bunch of different people
coming together to kind of meet the
conditions for the true joy boy in this
era yeah and of course i do think that
vega punk is going to be a wild card
and i think that toki still might end up
being a wild card even though a lot of
people are dismissing her as dead and
gone i think she still might be a walker
because i mean
that's that thing with oda man it's like
okay she has the ability to transport
through time and we never saw her body
so
you never know yeah and and she even
comes from the void sentry right it's
like she's exactly she's still a
chekhov's gun in some ways because
there has to be more to the fact that
she comes from the void center i also
feel like she knows how dangerous her
fruit could be if it got in the hands of
the wrong person so even if it might be
a thing of like all right i'll send
myself into the future on my deathbed
just so no one else can get the fruit
just something like that it's like so
she dies like a hundred years in the
future or something or she
i could totally see her cause she did
definitely get suffer injuries 20 years
ago but i could totally see her
kind of teleporting to this time and
maybe being on her deathbed but still
revealing some important information
about the void century yeah she does
i'd like her to be like okay i'm gonna
die anyway but i'd at least want to see
if my son and my daughter managed to you
know succeed if they managed to defeat
everybody you know mm-hmm yeah and maybe
divulge some crucial information about
the void century right before she dies i
think that would yeah i could totally
see oda doing that by the end of wano
yeah
and i mean we saw what happened with
kinemon you know he was so dead and
you know that okay so people got really
pissed at that i i think the explanation
actually worked but a lot of people got
mad i mean it does technically work but
it is kind of broken because then oh no
yeah 100 percent can't do law do that to
basically all of his allies just kind of
chop him up i guess he could like just
okay law is just like all right straw
hats let me cut you up from every angle
so you'll be slash proof from now on
yeah i mean that's pretty uh pretty
badass ability but yeah we'll see how it
goes wano is really gearing up to be a
crazy climactic end so absolutely
i'm excited to see it thank you so much
teching for coming on everybody man
everyone please check out teching's
channel like if you're a huge one-piece
fan it's basically a requirement to be
subscribed to teching 101 link in the
description thanks to everyone who
watched this long video until the end
don't forget to like and subscribe and
you can also check me out on twitter and
instagram at anime opera i want to give
a quick thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible special thank you to
alpha sigma and kyle salisbury these
guys are absolute mad lads and disciples
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our the one tear patrons the ones
who rise above all other clans including
ingrata algital pate heffa the
red-haired fox hinokamian water the
toasted cheek corey mcgowan the spike
lonely the car dylan isidor spidey life
canal tungsten tarkis big buddhist
jeremy cummings and che whitley finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers on hell cruise very
gucci alicia octor bonnie parks joanne
garcia fat boy games kaido might be a
duck jessica rabbit jeremy phillips
alibania temple king matthew and
demetrius water if you guys enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
oh and if you don't have a patreon
account becoming a youtube channel
member gives you the same perks as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you